hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about chargaff's rules in the early part
of the 20th century there were many many
scientists working on the question
surrounding DNA and mainly they were
working on first what is the genetic
material in the cell because it wasn't
always known that it was DNA and you may
have heard of some of those experiments
experiments by Griffith by Avery by
person and choice and others that found
that DNA was the genetic material in the
cell and then of course there were
additional experiments later by
scientists like Watson and Crick Wilkins
Franklin and people on tape heard of who
elucidated the actual structure of DNA
and today we're going to talk about the
contribution to those experiments by a
scientist named Merlin Charlie and those
contributions are better now known as
chargaff's rules so let's talk first
about rule number one sure enough found
that the DNA composition varies from
species to species
so DNA varies from species to species
this was important because it indicated
that DNA was a more credible candidate
for the style tonight material than
protein at the time that this work was
being done protein was considered a good
candidate for the genetic material of
the south one of the reasons for this is
that DNA is made of only four
nucleotides adenine thymine cytosine
guanine
whereas proteins are
made up of 20 different amino acids and
so it was thought a time that that
greater amount amino acids could explain
the greater diversity between species
but through the work of chargaff and
others it was determined that actually
DNA is the genetic material of the cell
and not poisoning now rule number two of
sharks rules is probably the one you're
more familiar with and it is that the
number of adenine and thymine
nucleotides so a and T are equal in a
species DNA and also that the number of
size of team and guanine nucleotides are
equal in a species DNA and so that means
that there were as many atoms as their
work by means and there were as many
cytosine as there were lines why is this
important well this piece of evidence
here rule number two was instrumental in
helping Watson and Crick whom I'm sure
you've heard of determine the double
helix structure of DNA if we look up
here at a basic model of this double
helix structure we see that it looks
almost like a ladder with rungs and each
rung is what we now call a base pair
and each base pair is made up of two
nucleotides either adenine and thymine
connected by hydrogen bonds or cytosine
and guanine also connected by hydrogen
bonds and so you can see how in this
model for every adenine there's a
thymine and for every cytosine there's a
one and so it was this piece of evidence
here determined by chargaff that helps
Watson and Crick along with other pieces
of and then some other scientists
develop this double helix model which
has since been confirmed by microscopy
so these are Stardust rules and that is
how they helped in determining the
structure of DNA so that is it for today
on biology but that's it thanks for
watching and I hope you learned a lot